Well.
Well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Jean.
Really big episode today.
A lot to get into.
I'm just overwhelmed with excitement that,
that it's about to go down.
You know what I mean?
Hmm.
You know what I'm saying?
You feel me?
You know I'm talking about.
All right,
let's get into this right here.
It's the Lambo episode.
It's going to be a good one guys.
Let's get into it,
right?
Fuck them.
Fuck.
Good luck.
Okay.
That's,
you're a hot black guy and you want to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move in,
you come move here,
but you've got to fuck the money.
I need to be fought a lot,
man.
Get rid free food.
Free ranch and everything else,
man.
He has a deal,
Oh,
it was Randy.
Don't loving.
Well,
we'll go.
We'll go to your mom's house with Tone Circle Christina.
Oh Man.
Good stuff.
Right?
Men are the absolute piggy rest of the pigs.
It's really crazy.
The world is full of this and it's the guys only criterion.
Is that the,
the the guy be black?
Yeah.
Like not even like [inaudible] fuck me.
Yeah,
there you go.
But he'd like,
he'd be a psycho.
Yeah.
You could have all kinds of diseases.
He's like,
I don't care.
As long as you ain't gotta fuck me.
Yup.
Yeah.
Be Black and you gotta be willing to,
to fuck me.
I mean,
you'd think there'd be more of a filter on it.
That's it.
What?
God's love the fuck and fuck.
Good.
Yeah.
If you're a hot black guy,
you want to fuck me at 2195.
Jesus Christ.
You got to fuck the irony.
I need to be fought a lot,
man.
You can get free food,
free rent and everything else,
man.
He has a deal man.
Part of it though,
does part of it as a woman make you realize just how,
how much uh,
the men's sexual drive can just hold them hostage in some ways.
This is just like,
I see this as a guy,
I'm like,
ah,
no worries at right now.
Yeah.
And I know where he's at right now.
I don't fathom it.
Like,
I don't,
I personally,
and I'm sure there are women out there just in a bad place.
He shouldn't have posted this.
You know,
just conversation.
I just push through.
Yeah,
just released the demons get through it,
man.
I just don't,
I don't know.
I've never been here as a woman like this,
desperate for,
for that,
you know,
most,
most of the time I don't think we see a lot of women with these types of videos
and then from jail,
homeless or,
or thug want to comp then true man,
you frank and moving to fuck me.
Piss.
Somebody beat me home.
You know he's seen me when I come over today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
Just try it out and he gave out his address.
Yeah.
He's like,
come find me.
He said homeless Jesus.
But as long as you're black and homeless and out of prison and you can bring
your friend,
your friend can watch if you want to try it out today.
Right.
It's like,
it's like a free trial.
What's the Promo Code?
Cheese and tried out and I fuck a piss.
Let me try it out.
She might only as fuck,
man.
I'm looking at the hardcore guys want to do it and I want to deliver it.
I'm a hot salt.
My trash come down plus fuck wow.
Where is he?
Like where is that?
I mean blue band cut out the address.
He was very thoughtful.
Email,
homeless.
That's really crazy.
I mean emotionally.
Whereas this guy,
oh yeah,
he's worse off than I thought and actually I think this is a,
this is dipping into drugs territory.
I don't think he's just backed up.
I think he's a,
I think he's fueled by some Benadryl.
Yes.
Ap might be on the Benadryl,
like 10 20 Benadryl.
Jesus Christ,
that guy,
you want to get horny,
God smoke weed,
but you got to take away Benadryl.
Maybe this guy took too many Benadryl and there's no one,
no one to help him want to move in.
You can move it a fuck the how much is that by the way?
There's a lot of people.
I think it would take this guy.
I think it's a good deal actually.
It's a great deal.
If you are homeless and black,
it's a really good deal.
If you meet those two criteria,
that's yeah,
that's all he's asking.
He didn't even say like big dicks and that added jail.
His standards are incredibly low,
but he didn't even say,
you know,
drug free disease,
free both Dick and ready to fuck.
Just a lack.
But here's the thing,
you can't just be black.
You also gotta be done a fuck this guy a lot.
A lot.
What is a lot do you think that's the thing?
That's a subjective term,
but I think he means it.
I don't think a lot.
Somebody really a lot,
you know,
today.
Tomorrow I was like,
no,
no.
I think this guy means like breakfast,
lunch and dinner or wants his rent.
He wants his food.
Damn.
How's the thing?
He'd get tired of you though.
I think he's,
you know,
he's the kind of guy that needs a new piece.
I think so.
What do you think his apartments like ty or super nice.
Huh?
Why do you think is so nice?
I mean,
he seems like he takes care of himself and he's like,
it takes care of that mustache.
That's what I'm saying.
Like he likes his look to be fresh food or something on the outside of his
mouth.
You know something I'm looking for hard core guys.
That mustache is insane too.
God [inaudible] me.
Yeah,
there's definitely a different place than I thought he was.
I mean,
I understood,
you know,
I mean,
I was telling her that exists too,
but I thought he was just like,
I'm fucking fired up.
He's just like,
oh,
whatever age on me.
If you want
Jesus,
he wants to be abused.
This guy try it all out my bills and trot out and we're fucking pissed on me.
Try it out.
It's applied only as fuck,
man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys want to do it and I want him to deliver it.
I'm a hot so my trash come down plus fuck.
Who is he posting this?
But I don't know.
Is this a craigslist video ad?
Those eyes.
Dot.
All the i's are terrifying.
I feel as though too,
you know,
if you're putting an offer like that out into the world,
you might want to record yourself in a more flattering light.
Maybe turn the light on,
maybe sit up.
He's laying back camera over him.
Yeah,
like maybe make yourself look more attractive.
like some people will know how to look attractive on camera.
You know what I mean?
It's like lighting
[inaudible]
not the dog.
Can't ask rapper party on his dog.
Now the thing,
this is either animal abuse or the dog loves it.
That's the thing.
That's what I wanted to discuss.
We don't know.
First of all,
the dog doesn't know that his dad is a celebrity.
So Q star,
huge star talent.
I will say that he kept a healthy distance,
you know?
Hey receiving keep bands smother him too.
Like he wasn't like sitting on them.
Right.
It wasn't abusive and he gave him a nice pet at the end.
That's the king.
Right.
Then this falls into nasty or not.
It's exactly right.
Do you think it's an STD or not?
I mean,
it depends on the dock because we've got two dogs.
One dog loves the farts.
One dog,
one dog.
You fart and his area and he gets up and he walks away.
Yeah,
that's easily.
so make another song.
One dog's heaven is another dog's hell.
Now if you're kicking ass rubbers,
dog,
you got to find this to be heaven because he farts 24 seven and there's a guy
that can fly
and the diag doesn't seem bothered by the Fart,
so I'm going to go with and not nasty.
This ain't,
this ain't that nasty.
I don't think it's too nasty.
Now is this an old video?
Because he looks thinner here.
I'm thinking this might be before he got the large.
He really blew up recently.
What else?
It says there's something else here.
Let's see.
Doug moved away.
The dog didn't move,
but he did turn his head slightly away.
What's Nastier?
When King asked rubber farts on his food and then eats it or how many farts on
near this dog?
It's the food.
The food is really gross.
It's nasty.
This is,
this is only nasty if you think farts are nasty,
but he's not like a,
I don't think he's abusing the dog and the dog's comfortable dog just moved to
Ted and he didn't like,
you know like sit on.
He was farting in his area.
I think it's fine.
This incorporates two of my favorite things.
Doggies and king ass rapper.
Yeah.
This is like the most perfect video ever made.
Yes I am.
Yeah.
That's like what our dog,
that's what faith does.
He was going to say that if the dog doesn't like it,
he will get up and leave and this would have a different feeling if he was like
holding the dog there and like yeah,
he's just farting near the dog and the dog made a choice to leave when it was
okay.
I'm okay with it.
Or didn't insist that the dog stay for the card so it wasn't,
it means a few feet above its head.
The animal activists or just all lit up right now.
Oh,
I know about him.
I probably get some emails.
How dare you find that dogs?
We're going to skip all over him.
Just see
on a dog.
Yeah.
On both of our dogs had several times for it on their heads to in bed.
They lay right there.
What can we do?
How,
where is this by the way?
Why is fighting on a dog?
It's so funny to me.
I don't know.
That's one of my life's joys,
you know,
you know how I was talking about the difference between relief and joy.
I would say farting on a dog's head qualifies as joy.
That's one of the few things that really lifts me up out of the doldrums.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
40 just farting is just great in general.
Oh,
so this is now,
so I want to talk about the Lambo Prank.
She's so fun
and the actual,
the video's gone.
They must have taken it down,
but so,
well,
just one of these things I'll,
I'll,
I'll explain.
So for people that don't know,
I mean most of you know that are fans of our show that yeah,
we've been doing,
I'm sober October and um,
talk to a birch with a heart of t the hard t and it included a being sober for
the month,
not drinking or taking drugs,
smoking weed.
And for you that's really not a challenge.
Not that big of a challenge,
a big deal.
Um,
and also 1590 minute hot yoga classes.
Have you farted in any of those classes?
No,
but the closest I came was today by far.
So today I finished number 15.
Congratulations.
You're done with sober October.
How do you feel recording this on the 26th?
So I still have a few days a spirit.
I feel like it's,
you know,
I'm glad to be done.
It was an interesting test in discipline,
which I'm a fan of.
I like challenges.
I like being challenged to do things.
Um,
I responded well to the weight loss challenge.
I like being challenged here.
It's fun.
It's fun to,
I think it's healthy for people in general to hear something like,
Hey,
I'm like just to test your discipline every once in a while.
In other words.
Sure.
24,
seven all the time.
No,
I mean it's not for me,
but I think if you have,
um,
the opportunity to just test yourself,
I think you learn things about yourself and you learn,
one of the things you learn is that you're capable,
probably have more than you think,
you know?
Yeah.
Um,
which is a,
it's a good thing to,
to,
to learn about,
right?
Yeah.
Can I tell you I,
cause I was today I thought about you saying that,
cause you said that to me earlier in the week and I was thinking about it and I
was like,
I feel like everyday life is,
is that challenge for me.
Like I,
I'm,
I'm so anxious and so,
um,
I'm just,
every day is a battle to just,
to just be normal.
Does that,
I know what I mean.
I feel like every day is an exercise in discipline.
Is that normal?
Is that how no,
no,
no.
And maybe that's why I don't like challenges.
Maybe.
I Dunno.
I mean,
I think what I mean though,
I know what you're,
how you're saying it,
I know exactly what you mean.
But what I'm talking about is more in terms of somebody like when it's like,
hey,
this is hard.
I don't want to do that thing.
You know,
like yeah,
go on a run.
Let's say if you're a runner,
you're a runner,
but let's say you're not in,
somebody says,
can you go run a mile?
And you're like,
ah,
I hate doing that.
But I mean like I'm physically capable of doing,
I just hate doing it.
Right.
And it's like,
get up and do that five times this week.
Ah,
fuck.
I don't want to do it.
And you think of all the reasons that it sucks,
but then you go,
I'm going to do that thing.
I know the thing that I'm capable of doing,
but it's difficult to do and I'm going to do it the whole time.
Whatever the plan is that kind of stick to it.
Yeah,
that kind of challenge.
Exercise and discipline.
Yeah.
It can.
Something that says I have to
be physical.
It could be like writing.
If you're like sit down at a computer,
right.
Hour a day or whatever.
I feel like I don't want to do that.
Yeah.
I know you don't want to do it,
but can you do it?
I think at the end of that challenge of let's say if it was right and you'd be,
oh wow,
this was greatly beneficial cause he,
he forced yourself to do something and then the rewards from that are pretty
good.
Well,
yeah,
I guess you could say [inaudible] and,
and dieting for me was my discipline thing.
Absolutely.
That actually really turned my life around mentally.
Cause then you go,
oh,
I can do this.
Like I'm not some schmuck that's just
a slave to their,
their whims,
you know?
Yeah.
I have no,
yeah,
I guess so.
I guess self-disciplined.
That's a good thing.
Well this is,
um,
so we've been doing this challenge and we poke fun at each other,
especially Ari burden.
I,
we used to little jabs at each other when we make videos.
Yeah.
Every Schaffer
burnt crystals and myself.
Um,
and we take a little jabs at each other and it's just,
you know,
we just have fun her crystals.
Yeah.
Cause it's the three of us and Joe,
um,
but you know,
we,
we have fun doing these videos.
Like let's put Instagram posts up and we'll just say like,
I finished the class so the other day,
uh,
should fear.
And Burt went to a class together and as they left,
they had the yoga instructor talk and they were like,
they were like making fun of me and Joe,
I forget what the,
one of the things they said,
they're like,
oh,
you're seeing toe Tom.
And then the guy was like,
oh that little short guy,
because that's pointed like Ari's jokes is that I'm short.
And then he's like in the Blue Porsche and the,
and they're like,
yeah.
He's like,
And then I saw a bird and,
and are so ridiculous,
like such ridiculous car.
And like he said,
cheesy,
you're driving his blue car.
And I,
and I saw that and I was like,
first of all,
it's not ridiculous.
And I go,
if you want to see,
ridiculous.
And you want to see cheesy,
we can step this thing up to a whole other level,
you know?
And I think like there's huge,
many layers to the car thing for me,
and particularly this car in particular that I decided to rent and take to this.
First of all,
I'm a car nut.
Like I'm a fanatic.
I love cars.
Yeah.
If somebody magazines,
yeah,
I sure I'm still hasn't changed since I was a kid.
I used to play
little toy cars,
you know,
um,
read every car magazine and I still buy them all the time.
I've always,
I've gone to car shows.
I love it.
I just love cars.
When you love cars there,
they usually fall into different categories for you.
You're like,
you know,
that shit sucks.
I wish I could get those.
Like these are the cars I love.
And then there's a category of car that you're like,
I get that someone's into that,
but it does nothing for me.
It's an absurd thing.
It just doesn't,
there's no,
it's like if you want to relate it to like human beings,
like someone's saying,
isn't that person attractive?
And you're like,
doesn't do anything for me.
Right.
I understand that you might think that person's attractive,
but he don't want to fuck that guy.
Right.
For Free Room and board.
There's a homeless guy out there that wants that.
Who wants to fuck that guy and pissing and and beat on him.
Just try it.
So something for everybody.
There's some for everyone.
For me,
Lamborghinis fall into that category.
They just do nothing for me.
I see them as comical,
ridiculous cars.
I see a Lamborghini the same way I see somebody with a pet tiger or like a mink
coat or like if somebody said like,
hey,
you like shoes.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
like she was like,
I got to shoes,
made a diamonds.
Do you want to wear them?
And I,
no,
I don't want to wear it.
That's ridiculous.
It doesn't do it.
It does nothing because it's so outrageous.
Outrageous.
A Lamborghini,
because we've been joking about that sort of thing.
Your joke,
it's longer than that.
This is a joke where even though maybe not 15 but like,
yeah,
you're right,
10 to 12 years old,
like it's always been just like a punchline to us.
Lamborghini,
who in their right mind like,
like a,
you were saying because it's so,
it's so flashy and garish.
It's like the sultan of Brunei has a Lamberg.
Exactly.
Only people who really want a tea,
like a lot of autonomy or just have so much money,
they don't know what to do.
And the Lamborghini,
the,
the efficiency,
there's no efficiency.
Number one,
there's no cup holders and a Lamborghini,
you can't even bring like your cup and put it in there.
You can't recline the seats because it's all and everything's made of Suede and
leather.
So you can't even spill or put a crumb in it.
It's such an absurd,
it's an absurd.
And the ones with the,
the,
the doors that go up like the wings.
So what you're gonna take your Lamborghini to the grocery store.
Where are you going to park it?
One of my favorite,
see you've told us before,
but it's been years favorite things we ever did.
Like as an ongoing joke of the Lamborghini Lamborghini,
so ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
I remember years ago we were living and the Rampart division,
yeah.
Did Not have a lot of money doing that.
I mean,
like,
you know,
we're trying to make rent and I called my dad and I go,
hey,
um,
we're going to,
I'm going to lease a Lamborghini.
And he goes,
what?
And I go,
I'm going at Lamborghini.
I said,
you know,
it's in La,
it's very important that you are perceived a certain way.
And so I'm going to figure it out.
Like we were to save some money,
this whole thing.
And it was like,
Dad,
you know,
when you pull up to like the club,
the comedy store,
the laugh factory,
you got to look like you're a big deal.
You can't just pull it up in like a Honda.
No.
You have to have a labor.
People need to think that you're really successful.
Yeah.
And he was like,
okay.
He goes,
I understand that.
And I said,
so,
you know,
like we're really gonna have to put some money together,
but I'm an Elise this thing and it's,
you know,
it's going to be like,
no.
But he used to,
you used to tell him the math.
Yeah,
I broke it down.
I said like,
we're,
we're putting like 30,000 days what we could get together.
I'm borrowing money from people,
all our,
all our savings and that kind of like drive at $100 a hundred miles a month,
something like that.
Like something so stupid.
And he's like,
well,
you know,
I support you.
It was so sweet.
He was so sweet and support.
Like he wasn't like,
that's the stupidest fucking thing ever.
He was like,
he was like,
okay,
like I get it.
I get it.
Yeah.
You got to look like you belong.
And I was like,
oh,
he's like,
you're in show business.
You got,
yeah.
Look like you're successful.
Yeah.
So that one like that did not get the reaction,
but I,
you know,
when I told him,
I was like,
no.
I even told him one time,
I was like,
I'm going to grow my hair out.
I'm gonna start combing it back and I'm going to grease it back and I'm,
I'm getting an earring but like it'll grow up.
And he was like,
yeah,
you got to stand out and look different.
Like totally
so wonderful because in la,
by the way,
the only time I've ever seen a Lamborghini is parked in front of like the
Beverly Hills Hotel.
Like some,
some Weirdo foreigner has rented one.
That philosophy that we're talking about of like the standing out,
there were so many people in this city who believed that they do go.
Like I'm going to grow the hair out and where the weird thing,
the leather sleeveless vest because I want to look like I'm different and
everyone's like,
no,
you're good.
Sure our,
because it is a certain type of personality that wants that Lamborghini level
attention.
Yeah.
I'm the guy that parks in front of the hotel so that everybody sees the car.
It felt horrible.
Let me tell you the full,
the full details of this.
So
I fucking go down there.
I go to this place to rent it.
I look online again,
we always talk about this.
By the way,
the first place that I emailed and called never even got back to me about it was
like one of the top rated exotic rental places.
I'm always,
I'm always just blown away by the place that doesn't reply to the person who's
like,
here's my email,
my phone number,
here's everything.
I want to rent a Lamborghini tomorrow.
And they'll,
and they're like advertising that that's what they do.
It's crazy.
So this place actually replies,
you know,
um,
they tell me,
here's what cars we have a,
it's called seven,
seven seven exotics.com.
And they were very,
you know,
very nice.
So I go down there and then the plan is,
what I'm going to do is go to hot yoga and I have these water bottles that
somebody gave to us.
So the plan is I'll rent this,
I'll get the Lamborghini,
he'll park it.
And then when I give them their water bottles,
they'll see you lower them out to the car with the walls.
Cause that was the thing I was
going to ask you is,
well,
how are you going to get the guys out to the parking lot after the class and
everyone can see the stupid car.
And the truth is I really just wanted,
the truth is that I would have just done this just for Bert.
Like that was,
he was the mark,
you know,
like,
uh,
Joe and Ari are like collateral damage like it sure.
It's a vert prank.
So I get down there and I'm like,
which one should I get?
And they're like,
how about this Orange Lamborghini?
And I go,
that's perfect.
That's crazy.
This is perfect.
It's so ridiculous.
Um,
I,
I leave the engine does this kind of funky thing when I'm a few miles away in
the orange lemon and the orange one,
I could not feel like a bigger dick by the way.
Everyone's looking at me horrible.
You know,
like I actually lay low,
like I'm not like check me out,
you know,
so everyone's staring people at stoplights.
You know,
I saw,
I pulled out of a driveway and I saw a lady go like her,
her mouth dropped and she was like,
but it looked horrified.
Yeah.
I rolled down the window.
I go,
don't get one.
It's stupid.
And she was like,
oh,
like she caught herself.
That would be the person where when I'm with LJ I go,
sweetie,
that's a douchebag.
Yeah,
yeah.
Can you say,
oh my God,
that's a douchebag.
So anyways,
the engine did this crazy thing on its own and it's like a spaceship in there.
I mean everything's,
they have to tell you like,
here's how you park,
here's,
here's how you,
you know,
turn this,
here's how the turn signal where there's none of,
it's intuitive.
So did you put your insurance policy?
Do you have to take out an additional thing?
Cause it's such an expensive car.
I used my own,
it was a risk,
but like I could have bought,
there is,
I didn't,
I use my own,
but yeah,
it was a calculated risk.
I was like,
I'm not going to take us a lot of places.
I think,
I think I'll be at home and then I yell gun back.
It's still a risk.
But I mean,
you know,
it was a gamble,
but it's anyways,
the engine does some crazy thing that I'm like,
what is it doing right now?
It was like on its own revving.
So I just,
I was like a couple of miles away and I called them and they're like,
well let us check it out.
Um,
how about uh,
just stay where you are and I'll bring you the convertible,
the white convertible.
And I go,
okay,
great.
I mean,
and for a second I was disappointed.
I was like,
oh no,
I don't have the,
the orange absurd car.
But what I realized as they pulled up and I got in the white one was that the
white one was more believable as something that I would get because the orange
line a little too crazy.
It's too much of a,
ha ha.
On those joke,
they would be like,
you didn't get an allowance when you told me that you got the white one.
I go,
oh,
that's even better.
Yeah.
Now Burt's really going to think that's what I put together after I was cause I
was driving.
I was like,
this is actually believable.
And it was a beautiful a lever.
Eda.
Yeah,
no,
it's like a stunning,
stunning like Red Suede.
Yeah.
Interior.
I mean it was black accents.
Yeah.
I mean it's nuts.
Do you think drives unlike anything I've ever been in.
And I would tell you I'm jumping ahead.
When I returned it,
the guy goes,
uh,
do you want to go for a quick ride?
In the event the door,
which is the,
the step up Lamborghini with a wick,
the doors that slide up but also has a much crazier engine.
And I remember thinking like,
how much crazier could this drive than the one that I've had for a day?
The hood icon,
the way who would icon,
what does that mean?
Hurricane?
Oh
shit bag.
So I get in the event the door and I'm like,
at first it starts and I'm like,
well that already feels different.
Like the old car,
it was like Blah Blah Blah.
The button to,
to start a Lamborghini is actually like a launchpad button.
It's like,
you know when you see in the movies,
you lift the lever.
Yeah.
It's like a flip a switch for the missile.
I mean it's an experience.
Here's the thing,
that whole,
the whole thing is a fun experience.
I totally recommend renting these cars.
Yeah.
Hundred percent.
So anyways,
he took me a couple blocks in the event,
the door,
and I was like,
this is 10 times crazier than the one I rented.
He was like,
I know this one's really fucking nuts and costs a few hundred thousand dollars
more cheese.
So anyways,
dialing it back now.
So the,
so that night,
the night that I get it,
I,
I ran it,
I take it home and I have a show at the comedy store and I go,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to take it to the store tonight and just,
you know,
Park like it's normal,
no big deal.
Yeah.
And then go do my spot and then go home.
Because a lot of famous comedians,
truth and most people wouldn't know this,
but a lot of really famous successful,
rich comedians do that.
Well they'll,
they'll roll up in a crazy car and then all the door guys will be like,
who's fucking car is that?
And then it's the talk of the comedy store comics.
Everybody has to exactly who pulled up in the Ferrari.
Now what I was hoping was that none of the guys were at the store that night and
this way,
like,
like rumors would start leaking cause that would be like a perfect ploy into it.
But what happened was he got added to the show I was doing and I saw a tweak or
like,
oh we just added already to the show.
And I'm like,
Ooh.
Then I was debating like,
it's going to blow the wad of having it at hot yoga because otherwise then it's
just like a comedy store parking lot.
Then then Burke hall,
he's like,
you're going to store tonight?
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
oh,
I'll see you there.
And then I go,
I'm not bringing it because I want to save it for hot yoga.
It's better.
It's better than the day time.
And absolutely.
And also just the four of us are not like the scene of the story,
not to explain it to all the comics.
So I go to the store and I wasn't gonna say anything to anybody,
but as I'm leaving the store,
Joe was also there.
He walks up to me and he was just,
whatever,
just bullshitting and I'm too excited.
I just get,
you know what I mean?
When you're like excited.
It's like when you're excited,
a joke.
Yeah.
You're
like,
I got this joke.
So I go out,
I tell you what I'm doing.
And he goes,
uh,
he goes,
what?
I said,
you know,
these guys made this video and they were like,
oh that Porsche.
So ridiculous.
Of course he's like,
how's that ridiculous.
I love portion.
I mean I know,
I know.
I go,
well,
so what I'm going to do is,
and I tell him I rent a Lamborghini to hot yet tomorrow he starts laughing like
really bad and I go and I'm just going to play it notch.
And he goes,
Oh yeah,
I go,
you got to help me sell.
He goes 100%.
I'll tell him you're doing great.
What's a good day?
He uh,
he 100% deserves all that stuff,
all that stuff.
Why not enjoy life?
Like what are you gonna do is save all your money.
So it was like,
it is perfectly lined up.
Then the next move is I get,
um,
you know,
the next day I'm just like,
wait,
cause you came home and then you told me that Joe was in on it yet I'm here to
here because I think it's more powerful if Joe does now because he and you can
kind of gang up on Bert and Ari and convince them that no,
this is a really good idea.
This is what successful men do.
What's wrong with you?
Like you're the asshole.
Exactly.
How much our Lamborghini's just so that,
all right.
So for people that don't know the one that I was driving,
some people online,
I have to say,
uh,
guests,
it was a 2005 or six.
It is a 2017 bro.
Like it's brand new.
It had 3,800 miles on it,
so it's out of the spray from the factory man.
Uh,
that one was 350,000.
That Aventador the one that he took me for a ride and afterward it was 500,000.
Crazy.
Yeah,
it's a lot.
But this was three 50.
That's crazy.
It's real nuts.
It's really fucking nuts.
It's silly unless you're a billionaire.
It's just silly.
It is.
It's the silliest,
which is the most fun to pretend like to me the amusement in this,
like the,
the joy in this would be to pretend like what's the big deal.
But I mean like to really sell it.
And that's what I kept imagining is that bird's gonna Freak out and I'm just
going to go like what?
I make a lot of money or just,
or just be like,
but what?
Like what am I going to save for my kid's college tuition scholarships.
Just not a big deal,
but also like that's not that much.
Yeah,
it's Sharon 50 times.
No big deal.
So,
oh God.
So of course I'm just,
I'm just,
I'm like,
I'm so antsy to go to class.
I want to make sure that I'm early cause I didn't want to blow the um,
like the show of it before class for some reason that we're sure not going to be
as fun.
Right.
So I showed up like half an hour early.
And funny enough,
as I'm pulling into hot yoga,
my phone rings,
I'm like pulling in the parking lot and it's Joe and I answer.
He goes,
you've got a white one.
And I go,
how?
You know?
He goes,
I'm right behind you guys.
I just saw a Lamborghini and I'd go,
that's gotta be
so I go,
yeah.
He was like,
he's like,
that's fucking crazy.
So we park like away from where I normally park.
So it wasn't like,
you know,
normally I park in one section of the parking lot,
I parked away from it and I go,
so after class I go,
I'll tell you an ra got your water bottles from this guy that sent them to us.
We'll walk over here.
And he's like,
all right,
cool.
So we go to class,
wait.
And that by the way,
is my favorite part of the story of like lowering them to the car and being like
at your water bottles right here in the trunk,
which is in the front of this car.
And then you're like,
oh,
what's the big deal?
It's my Lamborghini and I'm getting water bottle.
That such a great moment,
you know,
so like I really wanted to sell this hard.
So the way to sell it,
I thought it was to be very nonchalant.
Oh yeah.
You have to be like whatever.
What else?
This is what I did.
What's the big deal?
We finished class,
we're walking back and we're just talking about like at the time we had
finished,
you know,
I think,
uh,
Ari and I had finished number 14,
Joe and Bert had just finished number 13.
So we're talking this and that and he's like,
oh,
what are you doing tomorrow?
What are you doing the next day?
Blah,
blah,
blah.
And we started walking,
Ari and Joe or Aryan Bert had a road together.
So they're walking this way and I go,
I got your water bottle.
He's like,
Oh yeah,
cause our,
he really wanted that.
He goes like,
yeah,
I want that water bottle.
It's like a come here.
And we start walking and you know,
you're starting to see there's less cars that could be mine.
So it's like we're walking and I hear Burger.
So we got a Lamborghini over
and as he says that I reached in my pocket and I press unlock and the lights go
and he goes,
yeah,
sure.
And you know,
some people would ask,
like I told my cousin Brian about it and he's like,
you got to record.
And I was like,
if I just pull out my phone immediately too obvious.
So it was,
I think it was important to try to like
dial it back a little bit.
Yeah.
So I go home,
I go,
you want that water bottle,
right.
And I can,
I didn't even address,
I opened there,
I kiss,
keep hearing burgling sure
go.
So I opened the front hood,
which you can put a fucking laptop in,
in a Lamborghini and I pull out the,
I go,
I thought you wanted your water bottle.
I give it to Joe.
Joe Is of course.
He's like,
fuck yeah,
dude
balling.
Totally supportive.
It's supportive.
He's lad.
How you bald man.
Fuck yeah.
He's like,
wait,
where'd it go Tommy?
He's like six [inaudible] sick man.
And Ari is like,
oh,
like not really saying much he's doing is already thing.
Yeah,
he's doing his already thing.
Burt immediately goes,
W you rented this?
And I go,
no,
I think it was.
And he's looking at me like he's ignoring Joe and Ari talking.
He's like,
like really eyeball me,
you know,
cause he knows me.
He's like,
did you,
are you?
And I go,
yeah,
I go,
is that crazy?
He's like,
you bought a Lamborghini?
Yeah,
that's a great year.
That's great here.
He's like,
sure.
Yeah.
And then no teeth,
no angel,
no one Netflix,
you rented this.
And I go,
no.
And the thing is,
since it's a new car,
it has that,
uh,
the vin number,
vin sticker registration.
I go check my registration and it's still on there and right then our goes check
his registration and as he says that,
and I go,
oh,
I think they're actually going to go try to look at the registration.
Um,
Joe like says something else and it distracts them.
So they go back to the conversation.
Then we start like the things are there,
like what the fuck?
And I go,
I got a great deal.
I go,
the owner drove it for like three weeks,
so I've got like 40 grand off.
I only paid like 300,000 and they're like so much money.
I mean I go,
I thought that was a good deal.
It's a good deal.
Yeah.
And I'm just like,
totally like not giving in.
I'm like,
yeah,
it's awesome and you should see how this works.
So I start like,
oh,
you want me to turn it on and turn the car on?
I'm bird.
Sorry.
I just fucking or are you start going?
Who are you?
It was,
um,
let me see if I can,
he made this video.
Let's see if this place on Instagram.
Oh,
how funny.
The one thing I like to say about me and my friends is that fame hasn't changed
in any of us.
You hang out with Joe.
He's bow hunting is Jujitsu.
It's fucking marijuana.
Ari Shaffir that package to Asia by himself.
He could go backpack right now if you want it to.
Tommy's Mamma I Miss Sarah by is with the fucking brains blown out.
Like we're friends with Mace and puff Daddy.
Holy fucking shit.
So Funny Idiots,
but I could see,
you know,
I could see Burt's still,
like we would have a moment like that,
like for a video and then people kind of,
you know,
you start to regroup Lego and he would just look over.
I see him being like,
what the fuck he's in.
His in his mind is doing the math.
I could see the man,
he's like,
how many tickets is he like?
He was
the pog.
How much?
How did you get your podcasts?
Be me.
Even when we said like when we said bye to each other.
Yeah.
We all got in our car.
I got my car and I started to back up.
I turn and he's just looking,
he was like,
he just shook his head.
He was like,
Chinos,
can you crazy?
Could you imagine him going home to Leanne and be like,
oh,
I could push.
It's gotta be so mad.
Oh my God.
And I started to think about too,
how much fun it would be
if,
uh,
like the whole fun was the idea of him spiraling to the point of buying
something.
Like the dream would be that he was like,
Tom got a Lamborghini,
I'm going to get a corvette like something and then have him show up.
Like pulling the store.
Like,
oh my God.
I'm like,
oh,
I just had,
I just rented that thing.
And you're like,
well,
cause also last night when you,
when you got home,
um,
I was like,
well,
wouldn't it be great if we're thinking of ways to fuck with Burt further if you
and Joe Could Kinda team up and be like,
you know,
there,
there had that bad to get into a new one for like,
I texted him last night,
I texted them,
I go,
oh,
it's so fun.
It's not that unreasonable.
Bert,
you're making a lot of money this year.
Yeah.
I texted him last night,
I go,
want me to put you in touch with my guy?
He can get you into one for under 200,000
and he didn't reply.
Yeah.
Birds.
Um,
I started to get so many texts.
Your,
uh,
our agent,
yeah,
we share with our agent called me up about,
you know,
doing some dates and I go,
his name is Andrew.
I go,
Andrew,
have you seen my husband social media?
He goes,
no,
I own,
my husband got a fucking Lamborghini and I am furious.
I'm furious.
You need to call him right now.
And convinced him to return it because I am beside myself with anger.
And he goes,
okay,
I'm on it.
And then he calls you and then to which you told them the truth,
I told him after he goes,
uh,
he goes,
hey,
uh,
Tom,
hey,
it's me.
I'm from your local Lamborghini dealership.
Make sure everything's working all right.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
I'm real happy with him then.
And you know,
then he kinda like dropped character.
He goes,
so wow,
you got a Lamborghini?
And I go,
yeah.
And he's like,
Christina said she wasn't too thrilled about it.
And I go,
yeah.
He goes,
ah.
I really don't want to say congratulations.
And I go,
thanks.
I could tell that he was like,
he's like,
you're crazy.
I,
I tell him,
he started to laugh really hard and I go,
did you think I was totally unstable for a second?
He was,
absolutely.
Yeah,
it was.
I really was like,
wow,
this guy,
I thought I knew him a little bit.
Adam,
Adam from the store or they texted me,
I texted me.
He goes,
he goes,
I was going to text you yesterday to see if you'd lost your fucking
bill.
Burr texted me last night.
That thing really made the rounds.
He wrote like,
please take,
uh,
you know,
pictures.
He goes,
congrats on your new ride.
And it felt like kind of sincere,
you know?
So I feel I go,
I didn't get one.
I just rented one to mess with Bert.
Ha Ha.
And he wrote,
I love it.
All capital letters.
Hilarious.
Um,
so it was,
so then,
anyways,
and I had made this video
when I was,
um,
when I dropped it off and then I posted it a few hours ago,
just after I had talked to Burt this morning.
I talked to Burt this morning and we had a conversation that went,
you know,
left and right.
It wasn't like about it and at the end I was like,
yeah,
I know.
I said the main thing is like,
I definitely don't want things with us to ever change it.
Cause like I have a Lamborghini or like will you still be friends birthday?
And he was like,
no,
it's fucking,
it's,
it's look amazing.
There were still like,
he was real sensitive about it and as soon as I hung up,
I wrote,
you'll Burt,
have you seen this?
I posted this on guys,
the Jig is up.
I didn't buy a Lamborghini
back then.
I did.
I went to seven,
seven,
seven exotic.cup.com this is not a paid sponsorship.
I paid,
I rented it.
You can too.
I highly recommend doing that as opposed to,
I basically exist.
Said,
you know,
at the end of this I go,
I got you
Burt.
Like that.
Yeah.
Cause it was really just to see Bert and then he called me,
you fucking Dick.
You fucking,
yeah,
you had the whole time.
I was so blown away.
I was like,
there's no way he's got fucking stupid this federal,
let's say 40 grand on it.
I don't give a shit.
By the way,
if you didn't have,
I was being real in the moment and I know Joe was in on it.
He had to be in on it.
Good a penis,
work on news.
He's not that good of an actor.
Joe Is the whole time.
I was like,
look man,
you know she's a baller a off God.
Dammit.
Oh.
Ari was like,
I was in the car the whole time at all.
They're like,
dude,
there's no way you'd be.
I go,
Tom Thought that stupid.
He's not,
doesn't always look good.
It's important.
So I try,
so that's what they're doing
and I was like,
dude,
I'm from board.
He was like going a different coach.
I'm telling you man,
I can't.
Going through and looking at motorcycles all my last night because I was having
a feeling of being left out,
spending money on it.
That's exactly what we're talking about here.
Motorcycles,
all my account for dependent can grant.
I can,
I don't even want to spend five grand on a hot grill buyer.
Bullshit fixer upper motorcycle for fucking 10 grand.
I'm going to kill me and I started a go fund.
Me.
You and Joe are fucking assholes.
Hilarious.
See what I tell you.
I knew that Bert,
I'm pausing.
Oh,
I want it to go.
The dogs need to eat and stuff.
Okay.
Let's pause there after birds,
voicemails.
So I know a Risa and I want us all right.
We're back.
Uh,
there was a quick break.
Um,
I think the best is my favorite part of this whole thing.
First of all,
that was some of the best money I ever spent was renting that car.
And I would say again,
for car enthusiasts is really fun to rent a car there.
You're not committing to buying.
Yeah.
Even ones that aren't that expensive.
Renting a fun car to drive is a fun thing to do.
I totally get that.
My favorite thing though is that I,
you know,
I talked to bird after this and he was like,
he was,
I knew it.
I just knew that you weren't that stupid.
Like I knew you would do that,
but that Ari was like,
he's definitely dumb enough.
Hi.
Yeah,
right.
Ari was like,
Ari called me bite trash and then I was from Florida and that Florida people are
stupid and that we would definitely buy that guy's so damn rude.
Dare you Arie Aries.
That's how he is,
you know.
Um,
so anyways,
that was the lamp Lambo Prank.
I think that's,
you know,
uh,
no,
I don't know.
Was maybe Lambo Prank.
Um,
100% worth it.
So fun to see birds face.
So fun to get him to,
to spiral.
He was searching for motorcycles last night online.
I knew he would react that way.
I know.
I call it,
I go,
there's no way he is right now in his mind,
counting how much you're making.
And then he's going to find a way to match what you're doing.
God's work.
He's got to participate in some way.
W I bet Leanne last night was just like,
oh my God,
what has Tom done with it?
What if he as go fund me,
change with them?
Yes.
Bros.
So I know you guys are itching or some machines within remixes.
They keep coming in.
So it's my favorite thing.
Right.
And it's so fantastic.
Yeah,
sure.
Is Miss Ease within by Michael Hodgdon?
Yeah.
He turned it off
to Germany.
Yeah.
This is how I hear it.
I heard it in my head.
I heard it so much to say.
Yeah.
Great.
By the way,
this Halloween season two perfect.
Morocco.
It's a good song.
I love it.
Yeah,
that's it.
We're going on a ride.
We're ground the flow working on my flows of all the haters,
haters here is,
um,
of all the haters,
rage against the machines within,
oh my God.
Why didn't we think of that by Pete from one and a quarter.
Okay.
That's who made this one here
piece.
Yeah,
I liked that.
Terminator.
Gange
that's it.
Good.
It's really good.
Yeah.
Juice,
juice,
juice.
It's pretty good,
right?
It's really good,
by the way.
Um,
I think I already said this,
but I don't know if I said it only to you off camera and not on the show,
but the other really crazy thing that surprised me going back to the Lambo thing
was how many people were like,
the Internet always kicks you in the balls.
I got like hundreds and hundreds of people being like so happy for you.
I know.
It was like some people were like,
oh,
you're rich.
Fuck you.
Which was like,
all right man.
Like that was their take on it.
Like I like,
I used to like you so crazy.
It's such a crazy reaction.
Yeah.
But the majority of people were like so happy for you man.
Yeah,
we're adulation.
I will say that are our fans are genuinely,
that was very nice,
sweet and supportive of of stuff.
And that's,
it is so refreshing on the Internet,
which is a wasteland of hatred.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
I know.
So it's nice that I just,
that was just a real quick,
does it make a nice comment on Twitter or anywhere?
It blows me away when people don't kind.
You're like,
what?
I thought,
you know,
I'm in this douche mobile and it's a $300,000.
Like people are just going to be like,
ah.
And there was a few,
but if you read through the comments on my Instagram,
it's mostly people going,
you earned it.
Congratulations with it man.
Machines within.
Yeah.
I did see a bunch of machines with him,
but anyways,
I thought that was actually very surprising.
Yes.
Machines within also came in with video and music submissions.
Get the fuck Outta here of a few of these o m g
crazy
machines we then she ends with then.
Yeah,
I'm talking about machines with them.
Neda gun going to terminate a gun to my head to go and got a terminator gun.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Wow.
Within
Luke Luke,
you killed it with the redneck version of machines within incredible harmonica
work is amazing and doesn't really talented gs harmonica player right there.
That was really actually,
and I don't,
I'm not a huge fan of the harmonica.
Yup.
And I really enjoyed that.
That was great.
Yeah.
That guy's talented.
There's more,
well,
I told me,
Christina,
this is what Ukulele version and machines within all the way from the UK mom's
house on the coast.
I'm going to terminate again.
See 16
a gun for the haters.
Crabbers Travers.
Yeah,
dude,
thank you.
That was awesome.
Fantastic.
Amazing audience.
We have no international international,
and that was the other one came in.
Shut up
Nate from India.
The second song on the album.
No.
Hey,
make me
crazy
jeans.
Let them know.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Spiritually from hell.
Wow.
That's amazing.
That's a Nate from Indy.
Incredible.
So many.
I mean,
I feel like I'm serious.
There's so many incredibly musically inclined.
People who listen to this show,
I'm,
he knew such talented people.
I thought it was all just derelicts like us that listen,
I know there's really talented people.
I'm a little disappointed that we didn't get a song.
You know,
she's retarded song,
but you can only get so much.
She's retarded.
So let me see.
Do I see you?
I don't,
I don't see one.
No.
I was thinking that the,
she's retarded.
That could be a fun prank for spouses.
You could say that about your wife or husband in public when they act up,
we think this email.
Oh,
it's interesting.
Right?
Design means twins,
conjoined twins.
If they get a job,
do they get one salary or to dammit machines within f the haters navy.
That is an excellent question.
I hope that machines will then f the haters for places.
Hey Hitler.
Yeah,
me too.
Believe me,
especially as you're,
you're touring starts to pick up now and you hear it as many times as I did this
year,
walking to the stage as you get on stage and as the applause dies,
you know,
and they settled in for you to talk and you're like,
hello.
And then they go,
Hey Hitler like that.
And you're like,
Huh.
Well I was at Twitter yesterday doing the Twitter Q and a Santa Monica.
It's Super Fun.
Is that,
it's not official HQ,
right?
Cause that's up north,
but it's like Twitter,
la.
So there's offices in Denver,
San Francisco,
all these million places.
And um,
you know,
a lot of it's Mommy's asking questions.
And most of them were like,
Hey Hitler,
just wondering blah,
blah,
blah.
And the girls were like,
why is everybody saying,
Hey Hitler,
it's a joke.
My joke book at um,
at Yoga,
I didn't know it and our,
she drove this
and I go,
no,
he goes,
was not your notebook.
I'm like,
well,
this is my notebook.
And he opened it and at the top it says,
Hey,
Hitler.
And I go,
no,
that is mine.
It was like,
this was Hitler and it was yours.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's mine.
Because it was like,
it was a reminder to tell that story to somebody who knows what goes on my set
list.
A hot dump question.
Hey Mommy's,
you know,
they say if you drink milk with spicy foods,
it takes away some of the slicey.
I'm wondering if you were to pour milk on how you say asshole,
would it ease the pain of hot dumps?
Think love you at Gabe.
What a real thought provoking.
Another really good question.
Gosh,
I mean,
I don't see why it wouldn't if it works on your mouth with spices.
Yeah.
You know what else cools your Heinie is a total washlet three 50 he just
splashing some water on your Heinie.
Yes,
so I'd argue that any liquid really helps keeps your asshole.
Oh
crap,
we're out.
It's a good question.
I'm really interested if there's any employers who have hired or been around a
conjoined twin to see if they two salaries because they have separate rights.
They have their own individual rights to separate people.
Yeah.
They have different minds.
So how could you be like,
well we're just going to pay you this one thing.
They are two separate entities.
They are two separate people with different social security number.
Fascinating question,
right?
Yeah,
they have,
I'm sure they have,
you know,
license not dry or I don't think it can.
They drive.
Who's the driver?
I Dunno.
How do you wipe if you have no arms that came in?
Damn it.
Oh second.
Such a good dump today began thinking about people who are unable to have such a
time when the toilet,
my pondering of poop brought me to this question.
How do people without arms wipe their ass?
I'm really at a loss here.
I what I'm really at a loss at is not how they wipe at all.
How do you wipe outside of the home?
Because I'm sure there's a system you would set up at home.
You know there would be something like,
even though I don't want to rag on it something,
I don't know off the top of my,
but yeah,
I can imagine that there is something you would set up,
right?
Like a day in a,
in uh,
some device pushed the button for the big day.
It's a great question.
I mean these are,
you know,
I'm saying that,
but there's something if the no arm people out there are going to find us and
let us know there's some system but it's more interesting to me is like what
about an emergency dump out on the town?
That's really curious.
I mean,
I'm guessing alone if your arm less,
you might have a helper with you at all times.
No.
And then how do you,
how do you get it wrong?
Oh No,
I guess you can take an Uber now or most people don't have helpers.
I'd have a helper if I were aren't sure,
can't reach anything.
How are you going to,
how are you going to get your iPhone out and hit Uber?
Come get ya know arms.
Why is that a ridiculous question?
They don't have helpers if like a prosthetic and they,
you know,
if they don't,
they still can.
You can.
You can walk around and do what you need to do without an arm.
No arm,
two arms missing.
I don't have a helper.
This person did not mention prosthetics.
I'm literally imagining somebody with no arms right now.
They still don't be like,
I don't have arms.
I need a full time caregiver is not how that works because they would still,
they make do without their arms.
What's interesting is how they do it.
It's not a helper,
not a helper.
I don't know much about the armless Kim.
I'm just saying it's a fascinating question.
It is a fascinating question.
If you're black and you want to rent free lifestyle,
fuck me,
come over here and fuck me right now.
Piss on me.
Slap me,
hit me in my eyes.
He went to try it out and try it out and let's look a piss on me.
Try it out.
It's just going to as fuck,
man.
I'm looking for hardcore guys.
We know you are.
I want him to deliver it.
I'm a hot salt by trash.
Come down for this.
Fuck
his teeth.
Don't look good either and nothing's going on good.
God's love the fuck.
Fuck.
Look,
if you're a hot black,
got it.
Who Do you think is creepy?
Okay.
Would you rather,
would you rather
your a hot black guy?
Would you rather bang ugly?
Ron,
Jeremy?
Yeah,
and Ron.
Jeremy.
So good.
This is his retarded brother.
Yeah.
Dawn,
Jeremy.
So would you either bang this Guy Don Jeremy or the 2016 Benadryl Guy?
Oh my God,
he's,
they're both super horny.
Okay.
It's a filler of sealer shut.
Here's the thing,
Taylor up.
Are you doing the 16 Benadryl guy or this general?
As always,
I applaud you and your impromptu filler ups and would you,
you're really gifted at this.
This is what I would take for the networks to pitch.
If I were you,
if you were pitching ideas,
you know,
I am looking to pitch show a dog dog deck afternoon.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah,
right.
Wait a minute.
What about I'm gum gum gum with the chewables with the man love in the middle,
right?
Good idea.
Liking,
farting on dogs' heads is another TV show so far.
I mean,
I could see NBC,
ABC,
Fox,
CBS.
Where else are you going to take this thing?
The only,
the big ones are not a k.
These are broadcast network shows.
Yeah.
Okay.
So who are you going to bang?
Is it the 16 Benadryl?
Here's why it's interesting to me.
Um,
that's super hardy.
Here's the good news.
They're both enthusiastic lovers.
They're both definitely not.
Not horny.
You're right.
Um,
so for charge,
just to remind people who you're talking about,
just the people
who don't
want to be horny for two or three hours,
like you've never been in your life and you have access to marijuana too.
Good.
We'd listen to me.
Okay,
true.
We'd alone can get you really hornier than normal,
but it's been on drill.
Take about 10 12 minutes.
Girl before you want to have your sexual fun with your partner or whatever you
do or masturbate.
All right.
Yeah.
So true.
So this guy have a heart attack.
Go to the hospital at this hundred yard stare that's permanently in the eyes.
Um,
there's definitely plans and plots on the wall behind him of people that take
out,
um,
him and his manager elements weak.
And that's closet though.
He does have a nice closet behind it.
He's,
he's followed fucking gas for above.
Allude led a laughing gas or whatever it,
so it's him.
Do I want to fuck him or
lady the laying down,
you know,
homeless or rum or thug on the calm.
[inaudible] it's frank along with your man free range.
You can fuck me.
Piss.
Somebody beat me.
Oh Man.
Now I see me when I come up with today and try it out.
Try it out,
man.
Yeah,
I mean,
there two great.
You know,
we got to do a style to different styles.
You know what I wish we could do is like a dating game where we can match the
perfect homeless person with either of these gentlemen.
Yeah.
No,
that's good.
And they answer questions,
but you know,
this is silly fun.
Where,
I mean,
we could add a third.
How about the fuck me in my ass?
No,
let's keep it to the homeless guy gets raped by gay ghosts.
I think it's good to keep it to the two guys that can string sentences together.
But
who are you going forward?
It's a good,
it's really good because they're both alarming individuals and terrifying in
different ways.
See,
I think a lot of people
terrifying in different ways is an excellent frame.
Yeah.
A lot of people would in this situation would be like,
I'm staying away from the,
fuck me for free rent.
Black eyes.
Oof.
Why is that?
Well,
it's just,
it seems so direct and aggressive.
Sure.
And the aggression can be off putting to some people.
You say you go,
you go,
oh,
the Benadryl guy.
He's pretty chill.
He's just sitting on the couch.
He's just like,
smoke some weed.
But that guy has some really,
really scary things going on that you didn't necessarily see in that video.
Luckily for us,
we have more than one video of him.
Do you think he's making a suit out of lady skin and he's got a girl in a,
well,
I think the Benadryl guy's scary or actually I think there's a lot below the
surface.
That's what I'm saying.
The Ben Underground,
he,
he's got a girl that he's starving to make a lady's dress out of fun.
I would never see,
my family tried to get me to watch regular porn.
They call it fuck you in your porn and your,
the way you make out and your stupid boring fucking bullshit.
Okay.
This guy in a cabin with the [inaudible] that only he has the key to.
Is this the end of your life?
For sure,
but wait in the free rent guys like beat the piss out of me.
But that's what he's saying too.
He's like,
I don't like regular.
No,
no worries.
I like wild stuff and what's wrong with you?
But the other guy likes wild stuff too.
You wanted to be adventurous.
You like that.
The other guys direct in that he wants basically to be submissive.
He wants you to be a very dominant and aggressive.
This guy,
you like that now you like taking the lead.
I don't know.
That's your thing.
You're always,
when I,
I'm thinking the only thing that's going to,
I'm going to prom with the other guys.
I'm not black.
That's going to piss him off.
Well,
okay,
let's,
let's lift that.
No Lamborghini.
Amy,
let's left that requirement for this.
For the sake of this fellow reps sealer shut.
Yeah.
Um,
and now this guy's a serial killer.
You like serial killer?
No.
I like watching shows about them.
I don't like them.
You like them creepy?
No,
the two of you could talk about kilometers.
All of your own by your woman.
You're all a bunch of fucking pieces of shit.
God doesn't love those many of you anymore.
Here I am on the planet with your mother fucker.
Hmm.
Have a good day,
mother fucker.
Oh,
that's how my mom used to end her letters to me.
Huh?
The pupils are wild.
It is in the eyes with this guy.
He's severely mentally ill or just whacked out on the drugs.
The drugs aren't helping the mental decline,
let's put it that way.
I think I'd have to fuck the guy that wants to get pissed off for food and good
news.
Free Rent.
Bring that part.
I got a mortgage.
Jesus,
you're saving cash with that guy.
The mustache guy.
Uh,
you're having a good time.
Everyone.
It's a win win.
You pick up my lambo payments.
I don't know if he's capable of that.
Yeah,
but I mean he is giving you something too,
which is nice.
Free Rent.
You Andy.
You can bring a friend
least in a kid.
Fuck me.
You get a lease in a key.
Yeah.
Wow.
Now and you can also bring a buddy along.
So which buddy are you bringing along?
Oh,
that's interesting.
I'd be either bringing along bird or
sickle cell or Ari,
you know,
any,
any of those dudes would be down.
I mean Ari's kind of homeless all the time.
Yeah.
He kind of has like a homeless guy.
Vibes.
Yeah,
he does.
He looks how much this guy,
sorry.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
On the block.
He'd be like,
yeah,
but you look dirty and you look like you.
You know you live on the street and he's like,
you come in here,
piss on me.
Fuck me for rent.
I'll do.
Is this an airbnb over or I'll do it.
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Now see I,
oh man.
If I were a guy,
I guess in order to fill up concealer shut,
I would have to be a guy in this scenario
to go with you on this one because I am afraid that the Benadryl guy,
you cut you up so you would,
you would piss on and beat the other guy.
Sure.
And put a strap on and on.
It's free rent antibody gets to come along and he once he wants to be nailed.
Sure.
You do the strap on
big powerful strap on.
No prob.
Yeah.
Nope.
I'll practice before I go in on the levers here in front of me.
I don't know.
We went,
let me practice on,
you know,
bay.
We're talking lambo payments.
He said,
I don't think he could take over those payments.
What's your other payments payment?
Let's talk about the payments.
Payments on a Lamborghini,
you're doing it all wrong.
If it's three 2150 that's ridiculous.
You put 10,000 down and then your mother please only like 20 grand.
Let's do the math.
It's preposterous if you can't,
if you're not a multimillionaire,
your car loan calculator.
Okay,
a hundred and fifth she's retarded.
Yeah.
$350,000 Yamble let's say how many months?
Because they tell you it's really stupid to do longer than like 36 let's do the
financial advisors telling you like,
you know,
pay
it off within two to three years.
So let's say three years,
three year Lamborghini,
because otherwise you're paying way too much in interest.
So sure,
let's do 36 we're all about the value with this,
you know,
3% interest.
Sure.
All right.
Let's see.
All right,
so it's a pretty good deal.
I mean,
that's a low interest rate.
Yeah.
36 months.
They're loaning you $350,000 so your monthly payments are only $10,178 a month
for your car,
for your car.
Makes Sense.
Yeah.
And then you're talking great mileage on the gas.
I know I drove it.
I think I drove at 60 miles and I took down a little over a quarter of a tank.
So yeah.
I mean you're filling up pretty often.
You're filling it up like every day.
Yeah,
like pretty much every day.
Every other day you're filling up your tank.
How it like $60 a pop?
I don't know.
Fill up.
Yeah,
it's good.
You can only take a one person that on the 10 grand a your mind loan.
What about insurance too?
It's going to be not a joke to ensure if you're insuring a house,
it's crazy.
How expensive?
$10,000 a month for a car.
That is bananas.
Yeah,
that is.
That is a huge mortgage payment.
It's pretty well,
thank goodness
we can do that.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
man.
Okay,
let's see this,
but I will say that Lamborghini,
that that is just for the pleasure of it.
There is no utility in a Lamborghini.
It is all just for fun
is all pleasure and joy,
which well,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know anything about that.
What are you looking at now?
Trying to figure out the um,
what the insurance would be,
but yeah,
too much information assurance,
especially in California where there's so many uninsured motorists cause that's
what you're paying for is the people that don't have insurance.
Could you imagine,
could you imagine getting hit in that car and then you got to replace the
fucking the door that goes right.
I go cause I was telling him,
I was like,
it's so crazy to get into this business you have of buying exotic cars and then
renting them cause your overhead like to get into the business is like $5
million,
right?
Because yeah he has like Rolls Royce,
Bentley's Ferrari's Maserati's you know,
like all these exotic cars.
And he was like,
yeah,
it's crazy.
And I was like,
it's just so much fun.
He goes,
oh yeah,
when the transmission uh,
blue on one of these land bows,
it was a $45,000 to fix the transmission.
That's like a service on these things is no joke.
It
does make me think how many people in la are doing that exact thing that they
are just renting these fancy cars now that I think it's a lot.
It's a lot.
Yeah.
And now that I'm like,
oh,
what's that guy doing with a Ferrari?
Like these people are probably renting.
There's a lot of renters.
Yeah.
He told me how like the business
does.
Well,
yeah.
Especially in Beverly Hills and you know,
people want to look like,
you know,
where it's more obvious when you,
if you,
uh,
want to pay attention to how it's going.
If you see a Lamborghini or Ferrari on a residential street that's probably
owned when you see them parked or up and down road day.
Oh.
And that whole thing,
that's a renter.
That's somebody who got it for a trip,
which is,
I understand that.
Like I came to La,
I'm going to drive up rich people boulevard and I'm going to get this crazy,
crazy car.
Yeah.
Let's go shopping at the,
you know,
whatever point store.
Ralph Lauren.
Yeah.
Well this is,
I'm not one to five people buy.
This is super exciting.
We've been working on this for a minute and it's finally here.
We've talked about it for a while.
We have a holiday collection of,
uh,
your mom's house related products coming out.
They're out now.
A couple of them are on sale,
a couple of presale.
So this first one was the big one.
This is our first ever Christmas sweater and it is uh,
amazing.
It is one of the best things I have ever seen.
It's a,
it's a Christmas,
a legit Christmas sweater and it says Santa Claus wears jeans and it has sand
and he's wearing his jeans.
And here's what's really cool about this.
Um,
100% of the profit that comes from the Santa Claus wears jeans.
Christmas sweater will go to the children's Hospital of Los Angeles.
We're going to donate to their toy program,
wonder kids that are in the hospital and we'll document it.
So it's not just like you have just believe it.
We're going to,
uh,
you know,
make a video of like the shopping and dropping off some of the toys and gift
cards and stuff.
There's no better cause.
No better cause I'm so please check it out.
Go to Tom segura.com and click on my store or go to Merck method.com/
[inaudible] we also have,
um,
a couple other,
this red Christmas sweater.
The Santa Claus wears jeans,
it's red and it's got the white stitching of like snowflakes and it's got a
college.
So cool.
And it's a,
it's a real Christmas sweater.
You're going to wear it.
You're actually going to wear the hat,
the winter hat with the little ball on top with snowflakes.
And it says Santa Claus wears jeans.
Course.
That's,
um,
very fun.
And then this is something that like I've held onto,
I wanted to do this for years and I finally did it.
We're doing Christmas sweatshirts as well in different colors,
white,
green,
and red.
And who are you to tell me what Santa Claus looks like?
Is My,
so now we have Santa is black Hashtag IMH right?
You don't know my pronoun?
Yeah,
don't assume it.
Um,
we have Santa Claus is Asian.
No.
Yes,
I love it.
He is.
Oh,
that's great.
Santa Claus is Asian.
Santa Claus is black.
I love it.
Yeah.
And we also have,
for me at my nose,
we have Santa Claus is Latino and a green and he's wearing a sombrero and
hashtag ways anyways,
so it's awesome.
Like I said,
some of these our presale and they'll ship and like,
uh,
about three and a half weeks.
Some of these are on sale,
meaning they'll ship and less time,
maybe two weeks.
So that's our whole,
get them.
Now what's you're saying is get them now before the,
it gets really cold and before the holidays really,
you're can't get your
Christmas stuff now.
Um,
it's great.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
Christmas present if your significant other is a podcast fan or you just want to
have like a more unique holiday sweater or sweatshirt.
Uh,
the hat is awesome.
I have the hat,
they should,
they shipped it to us and I tell you the quality of all of these items,
Primo quality is impeccable.
But I have the hat,
yeah.
In the,
in our bedroom and it's fantastic.
And again,
what was the sweater?
All of them were great.
Santa Claus wears jeans.
The,
uh,
the sweater is incredible.
All going to a children's charity.
That's awesome too.
Right?
Yeah.
Very cool.
So very proud of that charity.
Um,
now to one of the more exciting things that we have come across in some time
here on this show,
I'm very happy to bring to your attention.
Nope.
That did not go as planned gene.
Hmm.
Here it is.
Try it again.
Uh,
I screwed it up.
I muted it for a second.
You know what happened?
Yeah.
I other shoe dropping in the wake of the Harvey Weinstein's sexual harassment
scandal and Golfing Hollywood,
new accusations against action stars.
No Daily Mail TV brings to light an audio tape and which the gal reveals his
outrageously profane attitude towards female journalists.
Uh
Huh.
Uh,
had a hard time.
That was
somebody who on a promotional tour,
he's there to talk about it,
fortunately about who you were.
Do you know who his wife for 10 years ago or they should go into pornography or
journalism if they want to hear that.
So unfortunately the,
the bleeps were unavoidable.
Sure.
I hate playing censored stuff on this podcast.
But,
um,
that's,
that's the only version that exists right now.
Some of the women aren't there.
Why do you think because of the subject matter most women don't like,
I won't even do it telling you what I think is good.
Um,
dumb.
Uh,
there's a buyer and wanted it to be taken off flavors here again,
October 3rd place.
I think he belongs in to do
so.
What this is,
this is all related to a story that broke,
you know,
it's like everyone's being taken down right now for sexual harassment.
Yeah.
You know,
all these things.
So there's a story that came that a woman who auditioned for one,
uh,
when,
when he was like,
you know,
making big $100 million,
whatever it makes or not.
Now,
yeah,
now they're like thousand dollar budgets.
But when he is doing those about 20 years ago,
um,
a woman claims that she was got the call,
like,
oh,
so called considering you for the lead,
you need to go to his house.
And she had the wherewithal to bring the casting director with her.
And he answered in like a silk robe and he just sat in a chair and watched her
audition.
And then when she left she got the call that like,
oh Stephen thought you did great.
He needs you to come back to do a private rehearsal.
Oh yeah.
All the private rehearsal in the row.
Any stolen his robe for it.
Well she turned it down.
Okay.
And so he gave her like a one line part.
Wow.
This story came out a couple of weeks ago and this stuff is in relation to those
stories.
Like the wow him telling somebody else about that.
Yeah.
And
you and all this and that
gentleman and you know,
I don't believe,
how can you come back the way you come at it,
not ever doing interview again.
Damn.
He's so mad at her for for this.
Yeah.
Cause this,
you know this bad press man,
there's no sure and Stevens used to a very high standard of good press.
Yeah.
Being a Russian recent citizen and,
and uh,
you know,
a of sorts and you know,
he's a talented guy and I am the king of in province for,
for you mind saying,
Geez,
hang of Improv,
you know?
Yeah.
Wow.
Who Knew?
Man?
I,
I really hope he does more.
He was like this.
I do too.
I was just looking at the,
his photo there without the jet black mustache and the jet black.
I think he might look better if he shaved that off.
Just cut it all off.
Right.
But keep the,
the um,
the gun range.
Yellow sunglasses.
No.
Right.
He stopped wearing those.
He has little ones now.
He went to the John Lennon's yeah,
the tiny spectacles.
Those are good.
Look much better.
And the,
the hair piece is darker and more full than it was.
I liked that too.
I mean,
I,
you know,
Ryan Sickler,
our good friend had a goatee for 15 years and he just shaved it off about a year
ago.
Yeah.
He looks 10 years younger.
I just saw him,
I did the crab feast of weeks ago.
And I mean it's like a different man.
Yeah.
I think there is an age where you should take off the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean he's just staging him.
It's not good.
Yeah.
Just be fat.
I mean at this point it might look better just to have a fat face.
Right.
And the way that the Harris cut,
it's actually making his cheeks look puffier.
He needs to either grow,
expand the width of that.
A beard.
Oh my God.
Her just cut it off or lose weight.
I could do that.
Oh my God.
He looks great.
We've,
yeah.
Oh that's bad.
It's so dark.
It's so,
so dark.
Who's his plugs aren't,
aren't,
aren't good.
Oh my God.
He's wearing his guid and meat poutine.
Yeah.
Vladimir Putin.
He's wearing a fucking g to the Kremlin or whatever it is.
He's eating a carrot.
Sure.
Such a weird,
and he looks so weird.
Such a weird look that he's got going.
Yeah.
Those tiny glasses that he would look at him back then.
Look how much thinner he was here.
Yeah,
that's him.
That's him in his heyday.
That's not Yani.
No nuts.
Does Steven ago.
You gotta be kidding me.
It's back in the days when it was attractive.
Well,
your eyes,
he was fucking superstar,
man.
He looks terrible.
But that one,
that one interview he did,
uh,
he had those crazy,
crazy glasses on that whereas here it is.
There's one is right?
Yeah.
It looks like a cartoon character.
Look good.
Look here.
This isn't,
how long ago was that?
That's old.
Because he was handsome.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Take this,
take the facial hair off.
How are you going to act like you didn't know he was handsome.
I didn't really,
I did not know
the guy.
You see what that makes them look 10 times crazier.
You know,
it's not,
it's not helping him to wear the Geeky and the glasses in public.
It's just,
this is not that.
You're just look crazy.
No.
You need to normalize the look a little.
Yeah,
I agree.
I don't even feel like he just needs to look more normal.
Yeah.
You know,
when you start,
you start to do crazier other things to distract from your body,
going to shit.
What happens is like he's just gained so much weight that he's like,
you know,
grow this.
Put some sunglasses look.
Cause you're trying to distract from from things going to shit,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean
it's just so,
you know,
we were talking about it today as we were driving around the neighborhood and we
saw a man wearing like those Kava Ricci pants from the 90s and then he had a
belt and then the shirt tucked in to the,
the,
the terrible nineties pants,
the hammer pants.
And it's because nobody loves him,
but he loves them.
And I think the problem was Steven Seagal is that he doesn't have a woman in his
life who tells him he looks ridiculous or who loves them,
who loves him.
She looked at any woman in his life is like,
you're that movie star.
Yeah.
You're the action star.
Go.
You know what you,
you're handsome without the jet black widow's peak and the jet black goatee.
You look terrible with that.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
It's stupid.
I don't let you out of the House with even,
you've corrected me.
Silly your time.
You almost went out of the house the other day to a pitch meeting wearing a
denim button down shirt and the denim pants.
But I mean I'm your,
I'm why a mate for life?
Hello?
Yeah,
but not not to that meaning I didn't let you out of the house.
Cause why?
Cause you love me.
Yes,
that's right.
Thank you Jean Haler I haven't a in Los a question that came in.
I have an in law that is quite heavy handed with the,
you know what I mean?
Oh,
am I supposed to answer?
Yes,
I know what you mean.
Every time I'm asked to follow along with the dumb story,
at what point am I supposed to stop applying?
What's the etiquette?
We're taking this kind of blasting.
I mean,
thanks for the giggles,
Roger.
You know what I'm saying now is that a,
you know what I mean?
Or you know what I'm saying?
This person says,
you know what I mean?
Fuck.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
You know what I mean?
You know,
and I need to check it out.
You know what I'm saying?
It's a fear,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Yo Shit.
I'm like shit.
You know what I'm saying?
You know I have a job there.
My life,
I never had a job,
um,
in that jail.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I'm like,
you know what I'm saying?
I feel like,
I feel like you got a,
you got to kind of leave the,
you know what I means alone.
You can't really stop it,
man shows at the what,
Mitch?
Yeah,
yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
We need your home.
Good motherfucker right there.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
you know what I'm saying?
He's like,
Oh fuck.
It's a ridiculous,
well,
here's the thing.
One time I was watching a mom discipline her kid who kept saying like,
um,
this little boy was learning to speak,
right?
What?
Four years old,
so different.
And he kept going and like,
um,
and like,
and the mom goes,
don't stop saying like,
um,
do you don't say like,
and at the time I thought,
gosh,
it's kind of cruel.
It kind of,
then it puts this thing in that kid's head like self consciousness.
Yeah.
Then again,
it is a verbal tick and until somebody points it out to you,
you need to become cognizant of it so bad.
Yeah.
Maybe if he answered him with the same amounts of,
is it,
you know,
you know what I'm saying?
Or you know,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Maybe if it was like,
well,
you know what I mean?
You know what I mean?
Like as a joke,
I think it would,
what would be funny is what he's proposing is to go,
yes,
you mean I know,
I know what you mean.
She's retarded.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I was like,
yeah,
yes.
I know what you mean.
That's true if he did do that.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause there was a time in high school when my BFF Shauna and I,
we said like a lot cause we're valley girls.
Yeah there was a point where she and I had to correct each other and we had to,
we had to be like,
like hey we're saying like way too much and you were calling each other out.
We were calling each other out because we realized that it had like at like had
gotten like too far like,
like too far.
And how did,
did it help?
Cause Shauna,
Shauna brought it up.
I remember she goes,
I think we're saying like too much bro.
And I was like what?
Like like what?
Like what bro?
Yeah cause she's like,
she's like we're saying like too much.
She's like,
she goes,
oh because I heard my brother on the phone and I think he was saying it,
you know like,
like,
and then you go,
wait a minute.
Am I saying that stuff too?
I say like too much now.
Of course we both were in California.
It's the land of like,
like,
like Bro,
like
no,
we leave,
we're leaving for the camping trip on the 20th oh boy.
Any Fain,
mommy,
Daddy,
Nikki
grammatically incorrect.
Me,
Faye,
Danny.
We have a bunch of us going and you and pop are supposed to come.
What am I going to pay?
Shit,
they give us all buckets with our names on it for what does that mean?
Well you can't go in my pocket and I can't go in New York so he don't get germs
spreading germs spread.
But where do I put my age on the pocket of my name on it.
I think you played with just salt.
Why would you say that to me?
How could I probably go to shit?
The pocket
and then at the end,
where do you call the shit though?
Like a tree.
A tree.
Sweet Old Lady.
It was being told that she's going to have to shit in a bucket if she goes on
this trip,
man,
you can't ask them old lady to shit in a bucket.
I mean,
she probably shits in a pan right now,
but not in a bucket you,
George Hw Bush does to the former president who's been accused of sexual
harassment.
Poor guy.
Why is he the poor guy?
He's old.
What does that supposed to mean?
I mean,
he can't,
you know,
it can't be held accountable for us for grabbing high knees.
Are you saying that he should get a free pass because he's old?
Yes.
I think it's even grosser when it's an old guy.
It's definitely more upsetting.
Let's see.
This lady said she saw the president's getting together.
She got a chance to meet him four years ago.
Okay.
He's 93,
so he was 89 spry 89,
89 years old.
Um,
he sexually assaulted me.
Didn't shake him.
He touched me from behind,
from his wheelchair with his wife,
Barbara by his side.
He told me a dirty joke all the while being photographed.
Touch me again.
Oh my God.
Um,
yeah,
it's wrong.
Just because it's so gross to be touched by that dude.
How creepy is that?
Um,
well,
would you want to get your butts squeeze by him?
Would I,
I wouldn't mind.
I really wouldn't mind.
And I wouldn't mind if an 89 year old woman,
like she,
she was at through intelligent as a picture and I go sure.
And I stood by her wheelchair and she went and she squeezed my heinie and she
was like a buzzy has to Kaka and you know,
I'd be like,
yeah,
okay.
I would be like,
that was crazy.
This old lady in a wheelchair just squeezed my ass and said something dirty to
me.
Port.
I think it's even more appalling when last fall a little people are gross and
creepy,
like old,
old,
like a scared of death.
I'm scared of catching her death.
Honest.
No,
I get that.
That's the uncomfortable feeling of being around the old.
But I'm sure for somebody doing something like let's say,
let's say,
let's just say what this scenario can happen to you.
A guy can go like,
hey,
uh,
so you brought the whole,
brought the milk machine with you today?
No,
I brought my coffee.
I see you brought the milk and then he,
and then he puts his cup,
he puts his cup in front of your tits and he's like,
can I get half and half from this one and skim from that one.
And he's like,
like that.
So is it,
is it worse than a 40 year old man does that 60 year old man or a 90 year old
men?
I think it's worse at the 90 year old because they're supposed to be sweet and
old and asexual.
When you're 90 it's supposed to kind of whittle away,
but isn't it less threatening?
I don't know.
I know that it's gross.
It's gross or the older they are,
it's gross.
But I mean Granddad,
but the,
the,
the 40 or 50 or 60 year old guy can actually like do something.
In other words,
like this guy's in a wheelchair.
He's like,
I remember when I saw it's like that.
And He,
you know,
he can barely,
but that's why it's even creepier and grosser cause he's like,
hey,
so you would feel worse about that really?
About the old guy.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
I'm asking.
I would honestly,
because you don't expect it as much from the older guy,
the younger guy,
you expect them to be creeps.
So you were like,
I saw that one coming.
The older person,
it's really,
it really catches you off guard when they're creepy.
Do you want to hear the statement?
Outgoing?
It's kind of funny.
Okay.
So they issued a statement.
I spokesman President Bush would never under any circumstance,
intentionally caused distress to anyone he should.
He had sincerely apologizes if his attempt at humor offended this person.
And then the,
this is what the next statement said.
At age 93 President Bush has been confined to a wheelchair for roughly five
years.
His arm falls on the lower waste of people with whom he takes pictures to try to
put people at ease.
The president routinely tells the same joke and on occasion he has padded
women's rears and what he intended to be a good natured manner.
Some have seen as innocent,
others clearly viewed as inappropriate to anyone.
He has offended.
The president sincerely apologize.
Oh,
so his,
he can't control his,
his arm.
That's what so then,
then don't fucking take pictures of people on that side of you,
but he can't,
he can't.
He's saying that his arm,
he can't control it.
So then he comes up with a stock line and arms God life as long like my cock
or something.
Then I think this might even be the picture.
Hilarious.
So like his left arm is probably like around her ass right now or near it.
You know what I mean?
And he's like,
I'll run up.
Fuck you.
Or I don't know what he's saying,
but he's,
he's probably like wipe all the way you might have out of the way to the top.
You Wipe Front to back.
You think so?
I don't think so.
Do you wipe down?
I'm sorry.
Always bothers me about gross old dudes and especially in wheelchairs.
I always look at their crutches.
Yeah.
And how mushy his big,
big,
big does your dick of balls do they do,
they spread the older you get.
Yeah,
and everything.
Everything's hanging.
Don't forget.
They're like everything,
every bit of skin [inaudible] everything is,
he has,
his face is drooping and we look at her shoulders.
Her tits are flat because you know your body's decaying.
Yeah.
Like I think when Fitzsimmons it was like you don't know if his Dick's big or
that's just like again,
just fallen over skin.
All right.
Yeah.
I um,
you know,
I bet hurt,
hurt a nightmare to grow old.
Her box can be in good shape either.
Oh,
I've seen it.
I told you I had to change a hundred year old lady for her birthday party and
her,
I hung out,
hung outside of her underwear.
I saw her labia hanging out and her tits were drooping out of her bra too.
Should I feel like it?
90 year old man said something like that to me.
I'd be like,
this guy's about to die
rather do the 90 year old guy you don't have to do.
And when we were talking about him saying something,
but that's not what I'm,
what'd you rather do?
The 90 year old guy or 16 Benadryls 16 Benadryl.
So I have to have sex with him either or.
It's 90 year old George
or Benadryl.
There's a chance that I'd killed the guy.
Yeah,
that's,
that's part of the would you rather?
That's part of the thing.
You're either risking your life for the Aluna tech to kill you or you're going
to break his hips.
Bye.
But fucking but sex and my dad would do you,
but sex George.
Hilarious.
That Benadryl guys.
Terrifying.
I'm watching mind hunter on Netflix right now.
Yeah.
He's in a manager or someone like him is in there.
Slices a girl's tits off.
I am not interested in that shit.
I forget who I'm talking to you.
I was like,
I am not interested in any of these kinds of shows.
Get women getting their kid,
their tits cut off and murderers and shit.
I don't want to watch hospitals stories.
I don't want to watch people dying of cancer.
I don't want to watch no fucking white bummer movies.
I don't want to watch black bomber movies and I don't want to watch any fucking
bummers.
Dude,
fuck that shit.
What's that movie now on the iTunes movie?
It's got the,
everyone loves it.
It's a black and the cover with like the light.
What's that shit called?
Moonlight.
Moonlight is not a buffer to black.
I'm not interested in in the black aids.
Bummer.
I don't.
I'm sure it's fantastic.
I just don't,
I can't.
I don't have the emotional bandwidth.
I cry at everything.
Oh,
I'm too sensitive.
I know.
Oh Man.
I feel too bad for people.
I too empathetic.
Fuck that shit all day.
It shouldn't.
The bucket handle.
Yeah.
We keep putting in carrying because when we walk to go see the,
you know the flowers or the flower with fission young,
if that to shit.
I can't
get the fuck outta here.
I love this one.
I like that idea.
You're shit and smell that.
Yeah.
She's got the right here.
It's part of the experience,
the experience part of the wet experienced grandma,
the experience experience and what I experienced a lot on my own.
Shit won't go camping.
I don't like that.
I love the lady that made this too.
She knew exactly what she was doing.
It was beautifully done.
What are we going to do?
One more.
That old baby going to die.
Well,
I mean who's going to take care of us?
Do we just check ourselves?
Anyone old folks home together?
Can we go to the same old folks home?
They'll keep it will keep us together,
right?
Oh yeah,
definitely.
I can't live without you.
You're going to die before me though.
Cause men always do shit.
What the fuck am I going to do?
And I'm older than you,
babe.
Do I have permission to get a boyfriend in the retirement home?
Um,
yeah,
of course.
Of course.
You can get it.
You can get a,
you can get a boyfriend.
There's no closing song in my closing song file.
Aw.
Wa Fitzy has a song for you.
Come here,
Schnitzel.
You want to sink?
Empty file.
God dammit.
Come here.
Nothing in here,
dad.
Okay.
Send me a song.
I love your mom's house.
It's a great show.
Thank you for having me.
Everybody knows I'm a dog.
I love this show.
Thank you for having meall.
No problem.
Your mom's house,
your mom's house did it.
The Christina Fuckboy remix.
Oh sure.
Yeah.
Alright.
Fuck boy.
Yeah,
that's a fun one.
All right.
This was a really fun hope you guys enjoyed it.
See you on the next one by January oven by Jean.
I love you.
Love you too.
Thank fuck boy is one of my favorite.
It's the PC version of Faggot,
fag bag.
I like,
fuck boy.
If I can't say Faggot,
I'm going to say fuck boy,
boy,
faggot.
Fuck boy,
boy,
boy.
Boy.
Sounds like you're already doing it.
You're already doing.
You're already doing it.